while President Trump spent some time
yesterday taking it easy with Kanye West
he let the entertainer to most of the
talking during an oval office meeting
before they had lunch western that
photo-op into another one of his vintage
viral moments major Garrett is at the
White House major good morning good
morning Kanye West fascinated amused and
silenced yes
silenced president Trump possibly for
the first time since inauguration day
the rapper's riffs ran the gamut race
prison reform liberalism his own mental
health a Superman cape what he called
the president's quote hero journey as
with more than a few things at the Trump
presidency had at a raw reality TV look
and feel yeah call it the wild west wing
how does it feel to be in the Oval
Office oh it is good energy in this
Kanye careening captivating I'm gonna go
ahead drop some bombs for you 98
percentile IQ test no mic drop but some
profanity with NFL great Jim Brown
quietly watching non-political no bull
put the beep on it however you want to
do it 5 seconds delay with a make
America great again hat West win tall
hero-worship on the president when I put
this hat off and maybe feel like
Superman then turn to lament the absence
of masculine role models then and now my
dad and my mom separated so I didn't
have a lot of male energy in my home and
also I'm married to a family that like
his wife Kim Kardashian whose own oval
office meeting led to the release of a
drug offender West was in the White
House to win clemency for another
prisoner Larry Hoover serving six life
terms for gang and drug offenses it's
very important for me to get Hoover out
because in an alternate universe I am
him near the end the president said West
could be a surrogate or a future
presidential candidate
speak for me anytime he wants he's been
a great guy smart cookie on the issue of
crime West that he came to the White
House with a message from Chicago for
the president don't you stop and frisk
stop and frisk is a police tacit tactic
where street interrogations can occur
without probable cause of an underlying
crime the Trump Justice Department
supports it as does the president during
this discussion West referred to mr.
Trump as bro and in the end the
president said he had an open mind
suggesting bianna on stop and frisk he
might reconsider just when you think
you've seen it all major the president
never ceases to amaze us and surprise I
use that phrase bianna I never ever used
that a lot of material for your second
book major I'm sure you know remember
the context - I mean that moment of sort
of refrigerator poetry was happening in
the middle of a major hurricane hitting
there was a time in American politics
where a president was allowed to do
anything but be laser-focused on the per
occasion arcane an international crisis
the words